but there's still a big difference
between flirting and being nice and
having a conversation with someone
what's that what's the difference well
the difference what's the difference
between someone playing hard to get and
flirting or not being interesting so
number one i think touching is a big
thing so for example like if i flirt i'm
gonna probably at some point touch a guy
if i have a conversation with a guy
where i'm laughing a couple of times and
with back and forth thing that's just a
conversation you think that's on you
though for like the guys you pick well
well i picked the wrong guy yeah i did i
did but but i do but not overall it's
just the men i've seen
all have the same thing i i'm not i'm
not picking because i i don't really
have that problem like like where it's
every time i date someone and i'm a very
i like i talk for a living you know what
i mean and i've just never really had
that problem where men in general are
stupid jealous so it just seems like
that's like an issue with either your
ability to pick or maybe something
you're doing
but you have to no but you have to
remember that you have to remember that
jealousy runs on both
female things well i know but i'm saying
if she's in the same situation over and
over again